Speaker 1: I want to start today with one of
Speaker 2: these totally
Speaker 1: dystopian horror stories that's
framed in our modern cultural and economic system
as entertainment or something nice
when in reality it is a story that
shows just how bad things are. And
I'm talking about this viral story
Speaker 2: of a cash
Speaker 1: scramble
Speaker 2: 5000
Speaker 1: $1 bills
Speaker 2: laid out on an ice rink
Speaker 1: in South Dakota, where during a
Speaker 2: hockey game during the
Speaker 1: Sioux Falls Stampede
hockey game on Saturday night, teachers from
nearby schools were invited to grab as many dollar
bills as possible in less than five minutes,
and the idea the point of this was it's $5000
that the teachers can secure to get supplies for
their classrooms. And the money was, of course,
donated. Not for nothing. It was a sponsorship.
See you Mortgage Direct donated the five
Speaker 2: thousand in dollar bills
Speaker 1: in exchange
Speaker 2: for sponsorship
Speaker 1: placement
on the event. Because they're so great and
it's an amazing thing that they're doing,
so they get publicity out of it, and
the idea is let the teachers go at it,
Speaker 2: picking up cash.
Speaker 1: And not only is it in listen.
Of course, it's demeaning to some degree
Speaker 2: to send people out to pick up
Speaker 1: dollar bills because it shows
a certain degree of financial need that
is often stigmatized in many cultures,
not just unique to the United States.
Speaker 2: The idea of you're scrambling for
Speaker 1: dollar bills and stuffing them in
your pants and in your, you know, wherever it,
wherever it is that you're stuffing them, there's,
you know, the idea that sort of while we're
more refined, we're not so crass that we get on
our hands and knees for dollar bill. So in some
sense, there's that aspect to it. But then it's
Speaker 2: teachers, but teachers
Speaker 1: for money, for
Speaker 2: supplies, for their
Speaker 1: classrooms. And it's
another one of these stories where if things were
functioning correctly, this wouldn't be necessary.
You know, the classic example.
Speaker 2: Breaking Bad.
Tremendous television program
Speaker 1: with Bryan Cranston as Walter White,
Speaker 2: as a
Speaker 1: high school science teacher
chemistry teacher who gets a diagnosis of lung
cancer and starts cooking meth to not only pay
for his treatment, but to leave some money
Speaker 2: for his family.
So it's a signal of yes, as
Speaker 1: a teacher is underpaid, right?
Because he needs to do this in order to pay for
the treatment and leave some money to his family.
But also in a country that has single payer
health care, universal health care of some kind,
you don't need to go to cooking and selling meth
in order to pay for your medical treatment. So in
many countries, Breaking Bad just never happens.
These are similar stories to the ones we've done,
where Little Jimmy or Little Shlomo, seven years
old, is raising money for Susie's cancer treatment
and he's making brownies and Blondie's, and
they're selling them at 75 cents each at school
to fundraise for Susie's cancer treatment. How
lovely. What an amazing show of love and empathy,
and it is those things, but it is dystopian
Speaker 2: that it is
Speaker 1: even necessary. Why are seven year olds
doing bake sales to raise money for someone else's
cancer treatment or machine? This is
Speaker 2: another one.
I think this might have been like
Speaker 1: a prosthetic, but the gist of the
Speaker 2: story was, you know,
Speaker 1: local machine shop welds
a wheelchair for some kid who can't afford the
wheelchair and his parents can't afford it. Well,
we had a differently organized medical system.
Speaker 2: You just get the wheelchair
Speaker 1: because it's covered by
social insurance or whatever other system
Speaker 2: is put in place,
Speaker 1: and that is very
similar to this entire South Dakota thing. So
is it demeaning to be crawling around on your
hands and knees for dollar bills? Sure. If it
were teachers crawling around on hands and knees
for themselves, for dollar bills than we would
say, maybe the teachers aren't paid enough. OK.
But this was teachers crawling around on hands and
knees to get a share of five grand to get supplies
Speaker 2: for their classrooms. And so
Speaker 1: maybe were not properly funding
Speaker 2: education, at least
Speaker 1: in South Dakota. There are
states where education is relatively well funded.
South Dakota, not a state known for a particularly
good infrastructure, health care or
educational funding. So at the end of the day,
we don't seek to. Take away from the humanity
of the people doing the thing right. When little
Jimmy says, I want Susie to get the cancer
treatment, so I'm going to do the bake sale.
Speaker 2: Jimmy's doing a great thing that should
Speaker 1: be praised when the local machine
shop says Kid can't afford a wheelchair.
We're going to weld one for that. Those are
great acts. When teachers want
Speaker 2: their students
Speaker 1: to have what they need in the
classroom, so they say, I'll get on my hands and
knees for dollar bills and stick them in my bra
and my jock strap or whatever it is. They're doing
a good thing. They're doing good thing,
Speaker 2: but it is
Speaker 1: the system that
has failed. If teachers,
Speaker 2: after four years
Speaker 1: of college,
many of them two more years for a master's
degree, maybe three, you end up on an ice rink,
wrestling four dollar bills to pay for pencils.
We have systems that have failed here, and it's
Speaker 2: horrifying, and it's OK for
Speaker 1: us to say that it's horrifying,
even if the teachers are doing a great
thing. And you know what? It's not even
like the mortgage company is a bad guy. They put
up the five grand. Sure. I mean, they did it in
Speaker 2: exchange for their sponsorship.
Speaker 1: It's still five grand. It's a systemic
problem that continues to rear its
head in these dystopian circumstances.